[Music]
hunger games is everywhere hunger games
mania continues to dominate this country
the movie has made over 300 million
dollars at the box office and Mattel
just announced it's gonna release a new
Barbie
based on the Hunger Games main character
Katniss Everdeen that's a photo of the
Barbie it's about time Barbie had a
crossbow right here but you can hunt
other kids in the wild with yeah go
ahead Katniss get skipper yeah it's you
or her well here's the crazy thing I'm
bringing this up for a reason The Hunger
Games is not the only movie getting its
own Barbie doll this is a trend now
Mattel is releasing Barbies based on
other popular films as well and we have
an exclusive sneak peek at some of the
dolls
check these out it's incredible yeah
they reach him love doll they know I
love dolls there's this one there's
Lorax Barbie right here
[Applause]
I would make a nice bottle brush yeah
exactly there's this one right here cuz
of the re-release to be released
Titanic Barbie has come out
you can put her in the freezer yeah
check this out very popular movie
franchise
get your own Ghost Rider Barbie terrible
just do it from the neck up Ghost Rider
part hey from the new movie for the new
Batman movie Dark Knight rising it's
Bane Barney everyone loves me
[Music]
check this out next Barbies based on the
upcoming movie battleship you've all
heard of this battleship movie
yeah it's called battleship Barbie right
here
it looks she looks like a hippie yeah
isn't that funny a hippie who serves in
the Navy hit people the battle ooh no
war guns uh and then finally check this
one out
it's skinny Jonah Hill Barbie
it's not a movie at all you can they can
all play together and do